- [Voiceover] We've already
looked at several ways
of writing linear equations.
You could write it in
slope-intercept form,
where it would be of the form
of Y is equal to MX plus B,
where M and B are constants.
M is the coefficient on
this MX term right over here
and M would represent the slope.
And then from B you're able to figure out
the y-intercept.
The Y,
you're able to figure out
the y-intercept from this.
Literally the graph that
represents the XY pairs
that satisfy this equation,
it would intersect the y-axis at the point
X equals zero, Y is equal to B.
And it's slope would be M.
We've already seen that multiple times.
We've also seen that you can also
express things in point-slope form.
So let me make it clear.
This is slope-intercept.
Slope- intercept.
And these are just different ways of
writing the same equations.
You can algebraically manipulate
from one to the other.
Another way is point-slope.
Point-slope form.
And in point-slope form,
if you know that some,
if you know that there's
an equation where the line
that represents the
solutions of that equation
has a slope M.
Slope is equal to M.
And if you know that X equals,
X equals A, Y equals B,
satisfies that equation,
then in point-slope form you
can express the equation as
Y minus B is equal to
M times X minus A.
This is point-slope form
and we do videos on that.
But what I really want
to get into in this video
is another form.
And it's a form that you
might have already seen.
And that is standard form.
Standard.
Standard form.
And standard form takes the shape of
AX plus BY is equal to C,
where A, B, and C are integers.
And what I want to do in this video,
like we've done in the ones on point-slope
and slope-intercept is get an appreciation
for what is standard form good at
and what is standard form less good at?
So let's give a tangible example here.
So let's say I have the linear equation,
it's in standard form,
9X plus
16Y is equal to 72.
And we wanted to graph this.
So the thing that standard
form is really good for
is figuring out, not just the y-intercept,
y-intercept is pretty good if you're
using slope-intercept form,
but we can find out the
y-intercept pretty clearly
from standard form and the x-intercept.
The x-intercept isn't
so easy to figure out
from these other forms right over here.
So how do we do that?
Well to figure out the x and y-intercepts,
let's just set up a little table here,
X comma Y,
and so the x-intercept is going to happen
when Y is equal to zero.
And the y-intercept is going to happen
when X is equal to zero.
So when Y is zero, what is X?
So when Y is zero, 16 times zero is zero,
that term disappears,
and you're left with 9X is equal to 72.
So if nine times X is 72,
72 divided by nine is eight.
So X would be equal to eight.
So once again, that was
pretty easy to figure out.
This term goes away and
you just have to say hey,
nine times X is 72, X would be eight.
When Y is equal to zero, X is eight.
So the point, let's see,
Y is zero, X is one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight.
That's this point,
that right over here.
This point right over
here is the x-intercept.
When we talk about x-intercepts
we're referring to the point
where the line actually
intersects the x-axis.
Now what about the y-intercept?
Well, we said X equals
zero, this disappears.
And we're left with 16Y is equal to 72.
And so we could solve,
we could solve that.
So we could say, alright
16Y is equal to 72.
And then divide both sides by 16.
We get Y is equal to 72 over 16.
And let's see, what is that equal to?
That is equal to, let's see,
they're both divisible by eight,
so that's nine over two.
Or we could say it's 4.5.
So when X is zero, Y is 4.5.
And so, we could plot that point as well.
X is zero, Y is one, two, three,
4.5.
And just with these two
points, two points are enough
to graph a line, we can now graph it.
So let's do that.
So let me,
oops, though I was using the tool
that would draw a straight line.
Let me see if I can...
So the line will look something like that.
There you have it.
I've just graphed,
I've just graphed, this is
the line that represents
all the X and Y pairs
that satisfy the equation
9X plus 16Y is equal to 72.
Now, I mentioned standard
form's good at certain things
and the good thing that standard form is,
where it's maybe somewhat unique relative
to the other forms we looked at,
is it's very easy to
figure out the x-intercept.
It was very easy to
figure out the x-intercept
from standard form.
And it wasn't too hard to figure
out the y-intercept either.
If we looked at slope-intercept form,
the y-intercept just
kinda jumps out at you.
At point-slope form, neither
the x nor the y-intercept
kind of jump out at you.
The place where slope-intercept
or point-slope form
are frankly better is
that it's pretty easy
to pick out the slope here,
while in standard form you would have to
do a little bit of work.
You could use these two points,
you could use the x and y-intercepts
as two points and figure
out the slope from there.
So you can literally say,
"Okay, if I'm going from
"this point to this point, my change in X
"to go from eight to
zero is negative eight.
"And to go from zero to 4.5,"
I wrote that little delta
there unnecessarily.
Let me.
So when you go from eight to zero,
your change in X is
equal to negative eight.
And to go from zero to 4.5,
your change in Y is going to be 4.5.
So your slope,
once you've figured this out,
you could say, "Okay, this is going to be
"change in Y, 4.5, over change in X,
"over negative 8."
And since I, at least I
don't like a decimal up here,
let's multiply the numerator
and the denominator by two.
You get negative nine over 16.
Now once again, we had to do
a little bit of work here.
We either use these two points,
it didn't just jump
immediately out of this,
although you might see a
little bit of a pattern
of what's going on here.
But you still have to think about
is it negative? Is it positive?
You have to do a little bit
of algebraic manipulation.
Or, what I typically do if
I'm looking for the slope,
I actually might put this into,
into one of the other forms.
Especially slope-intercept form.
But standard form by itself,
great for figuring out
both the x and y-intercepts
and it's frankly not that
hard to convert it to
slope-intercept form.
Let's do that
just to make it clear.
So if you start with 9X,
let me do that in yellow.
If we start with 9X plus 16Y
is equal to 72
and we want to put it
in slope-intercept form,
we can subtract 9X from both sides.
You get 16Y is equal to
negative 9X, plus 72.
And then divide both sides by 16.
So divide everthing
by 16.
And you'll be left with Y is equal to
negative 9/16X, that's the slope,
you see it right there,
plus 72 over 16, we already figured out
that's 9/2 or 4.5.
So I could write, oh I'll
just write that as 4.5.
And this form over here, much
easier to figure out the slope
and, actually, the
y-intercept jumps out at you.
But the x-intercept isn't as obvious.